right
my first 1970s recipe challenge tonight
is the most famous feminist in the world
for no mother-in-law jokes for me
tonight
Janine Grier welcome are you what you
cooking doc I love wash duck a L'Orange
white duck a L'Orange I didn't want to
give you the chance to show off with six
young blond baying your fringe my muj
free I'm sorry I thought being a staunch
feminist you wouldn't want to cook if
you cook only when you want to cook then
it's fun okay okay if what you're doing
is dumping hash on the table every day
it's no fun at all no I used to wear my
apron all the time I was famous for the
apron so you burn your bra but you kept
your apron so you rubbing your duck in
seasoned flour yes sir and that gets the
skin a lot crispier and this is the plan
right right - jemaine's using the whole
duck we're gonna do a duck breast and
make our sauce always the cure little
bit of chicken stock and so that was
some Kevin Eric cabbage
I've got explain about my stock as well
oh my I won't throw anything away I like
that this stock is made out of a wood
pigeon that my dog caught yesterday
morning and it makes an ugly terrible
mistake the blind tasters may have to be
rushed off and the secret ingredient is
in here this is 15 year old failed
Cybil marmalade which didn't set because
I cooked it for too long I come Bleen
pairings for this recipe challenge the
last 15 years that's nice so who do you
think the feminist icon who would you
say they are today show coal no no
that's not enough over yes she's too
thin I agree there you have see right I
wish I could say Katie price because I
think the girls are genius yeah except
that I also think that she's destroying
herself and that's not a pretty picture
no in terms of the cosmetic surgery and
everything there it doesn't eat so a
strong feminist is not allowed to be
thin not really a healthy girl is affect
bottoms creature
now we go Joshua's give her brains or
brought in a man my grandmother used to
say you should watch out for those
skinny men they're all dick is what she
used to say she was right about me in
spirit my grandmother right duck is out
the wrested skins nice and crispy and
start to make the orange sauce I'm gonna
make a really nice caramel that will
help give the base on the sauce as well
as our love of food
we're both known for swearing Michael
grade is saying that nobody should be
swearing oh ma I was red was there ever
a bandwagon he didn't jump on I have the
F word you've been a big fan of the C
word and that mean cook along I was
intrigued by your fascination of the C
word how open and honest and how you
found it so interesting to put out there
why is that because it's such a powerful
word very powerful it really makes
strong men grow pale it's more powerful
in the F word that's tough you know life
but you described it in relation to food
hoisters caviar yeah why do they all
taste like that and why does everybody
hate them well you know everything a
country that won't eat an oyster I
wonder where that is right finish my
sauce a little knob of butter that gives
it a nice shine and oranges right the
very last minute and would you like me
to help you in a non sexist way that is
beautiful pink really think you clearly
know your food yeah you're happy now I
am scared yours looks great
okay good luck my darling check them to
the testers come out with the right
result yes